Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Before we begin, I just want to let you know that this episode actually has two parts. It has basically like, I guess, a sister episode over on my other podcast mantra. So if you prefer a more kind of compact, succinct version of this episode to start your day or to start your week,
大家好，欢迎回到“20多岁心理学”，在这里我们探讨20多岁时经历的一些重大生活变化与转型，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。大家好。欢迎再次来到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听友、老听友，无论你们身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你们能回来收听新的一集，当然，我们将在节目中剖析20多岁时的心理。在开始之前，我只想告诉大家，这一集其实分为两个部分。它基本上可以算作，我猜，是我另一个播客《Mantra》的姊妹篇。所以，如果你更喜欢精简、紧凑一点的版本来开启你的一天或一周，
I'm going to leave a link in the description of this episode for you guys to go and check. it out. I would love if you just gave mantra a try. I'm sure if you love this podcast, you will love that podcast because it's basically the psychology of your 20s, but more spiritual, more philosophical, more meditative. So yeah, go check it out. But as for our topic, today, we're going to talk about confidence and what it is about confident people that is so alluring, so fabulous, and how we can emulate it, how we can cultivate this. brilliant, bright, amazing attitude because confidence, my friends, it's actually not something that you are born with. It is a skill, a skill that you can develop. One of my closest friends,
我会在本集的简介中留下一条链接，供大家去查看。如果你能试听一下《Mantra》，我将不胜感激。我确信，如果你喜欢这个播客，你也会喜欢那个播客，因为它基本上就是“20多岁心理学”，但更加精神、更加哲学、更加注重冥想。所以，去看一看吧。至于我们今天的话题，我们将讨论自信，以及自信的人究竟有什么魔力，为什么他们如此迷人、如此出色，以及我们如何能够效仿他们，如何培养这种，辉煌、闪耀、惊艳的态度，因为自信，我的朋友们，实际上并不是你生来就有的。它是一种技能，一种你可以培养的技能。我最要好的朋友之一，
Percy actually inspired this episode, friend of the show, we love Percy. She is what seemingly, well, she seemingly is a very confident person. She just approaches every single social situation, every work presentation, every first date, with just such a grounded, secure mindset. It's honestly, it's sexy. Like, she is so magnetic to watch. And sometimes I've even, like, found myself just being like, where did this come from? Like, who is this amazing woman? Because her confidence is like an aura.
珀西其实是这一集的灵感来源，节目老朋友了，我们都很喜欢珀西。她是一个看上去，嗯，她看上去是一个非常自信的人。她应对每一个社交场合、每一次工作汇报、每一次第一次约会，都带着如此扎实、稳妥的心态。老实说，这太迷人了。就好像，看着她充满磁场。有时我甚至发现自己会想：这自信是从哪里来的？就像，这个了不起的女性是谁？因为她的自信就像一层光环。
It's like a color that almost surrounds her. And I think it's so easy to observe people like her and conclude that she was simply born with this. This is always who she was going to become. But the thing is, I've been friends with Percy for some time, for a long time, and I know her very well. And I know that this is not always what she was like. She was a very shy, reserved kid. I know she was bullied quite badly. I know she really struggled. And so it really got me thinking, what does she kind of know that we don't? Like, what is this formula that she has? What are the profound kind of psychological principles or shifts that delineate people who are confident and people who are not confident? What is it about the history,
就像一种几乎环绕着她的颜色。我认为，观察像她这样的人，然后得出结论认为她生来如此，这实在是太容易了。她注定会成为这样的人。但问题是，我和珀西做朋友有一段时间了，是很长时间了，我非常了解她。我知道她以前并不是一直这样的。她以前是个非常害羞、内向的孩子。我知道她曾遭受过很严重的霸凌。我知道她经历过很多挣扎。所以这真的让我思考，她到底知道些什么而我们不知道？就像，她拥有的是什么公式？究竟是什么深刻的心理原则或转变，勾勒出了自信的人和不自信的人的区别？到底是什么历史，
their upbringing, their personality, whatever it is? And what about that can we change? What about ourselves can we kind of work with to come into any situation and just feel like we own the room, feel like we deserve and belong to be there? Because once we understand, And the science of confidence, once we kind of break down the myth that confidence is only something that you are born with, we really do become unstoppable. Like we become unstoppable in work, in romance, in friendship, in loving ourselves, in directing our lives. You know, the list could go on and on and on.
他们的成长经历、性格，不管是什么？其中有什么是我们可以改变的？我们身上的什么特质可以加以塑造，从而走入任何场合都觉得自己能掌控全场，觉得自己理应属于这里、属于这个地方？因为一旦我们理解了，自信的科学，一旦我们打破了自信是生来俱有的这种迷思，我们真的就会变得势不可挡。我们在工作中、在爱情中、在友情中、在爱自己中、在掌控自己的人生中，都会变得势不可挡。你知道，这个名单可以没完没了地列下去。
So where do we begin? What do we do? How do we get there? That is exactly what we are going to talk about today. Your formula for confidence. Let's get into it. This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed human.
那么我们从哪里开始？我们该怎么做？我们如何达到那种状态？这正是我们今天要讨论的内容。你的自信公式。让我们切入正题。这是一档I-Heart播客。保证由真人呈现。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kier Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
嘿，最近怎么样，各位？欢迎收听《艰难成长的教训》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一位懂行的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着一副盔甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就非得这么做。在AHA广播应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难成长的教训》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian. Michael Mancini.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安。迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我的天呐。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困的爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方收听《受困的爱》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、体能和建立抗逆力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终将成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方收听《2%》。也就是“数字2”百分之。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约定时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此脱身。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So let's begin by dismantling this core assumption or core misconception, I should say, that confidence is a fixed personal attribute. You either have it or you don't. Is that true or not?
他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方收听《闺蜜：相信我，宝贝》。那么，让我们首先打破这个核心假设或核心误解，我应该这么说，即自信是一种固定的人格特质。你要么有，要么没有。这是真的还是假的？
Well, I'm going to give you the answer right now, and then I'm going to give you the explanation. The answer is, no, it's not. According to research, including a really comprehensive study on the heritability of confidence conducted in 2021, confidence is only between 9 to 28% heritable. What that means, if you don't understand your next, because sometimes I barely do, is that the majority of our confidence, somewhere between 72 and 91% is shaped by things like environment, experiences, mindset, choices, not just your genetics, not just things that feel outside of your orbit of control. For the most part, something like confidence is something
好吧，我马上就给你答案，然后我会给出解释。答案是：不，不是这样的。根据研究，包括2021年进行的一项关于自信遗传性的非常全面的研究，自信的遗传率仅在9%到28%之间。如果你没听懂接下来的话（因为有时我自己也勉强能懂），这意味着我们的大多数自信，大约72%到91%，是由环境、经历、心态、选择等因素塑造的，而不仅仅是你的基因，不仅仅是那些感觉超出了你控制范围的事情。在很大程度上，像自信这样的东西是
that we can change. We can kind of intercept and form to our desires. And to truly understand why this is the case and to truly understand like the foundation of confidence, you have to understand one of its core ingredients, which is self-efficacy. Self-efficacy is a concept that was first-named or labeled, I guess, by someone called Albert Bondura, a very famous social psychologist who we talk about a lot. And it is basically our belief in our capacity to execute the behaviors necessary to produce specific performance attainments. In simpler terms, because that is such a convoluted definition, it is your belief that you can successfully perform a given task, you can achieve a particular goal, you can, I guess, present yourself a specific way based
我们可以改变的。我们可以进行干预并把它塑造长成我们所期望的样子。要真正理解为什么会这样，并真正理解自信的基础，你必须理解它的核心要素之一，即自我效能感。自我效能感这个概念最初是由阿尔伯特·班杜拉提出或命名的，他是一位我们经常谈论的非常著名的社会心理学家。它基本上是指我们对自己有能力执行产生特定绩效成果所需行为的信念。用更简单的话来说，因为这个定义太拗口了，它就是你相信自己能够成功完成某项任务、实现某个特定目标，或者我猜，能够根据
on your intentions and your desires. It is not so much your belief that things will go well. It's not so much your belief that people will like you. It's not your belief in anything outside of your control. It is belief in yourself. Before we can become confident, we need self-efficacy. And the great thing about self-efficacy is that it can only be built and earned. It cannot just be granted to us. It is not either there or not the moment we are born. So there are four primary sources through which self-efficacy is developed and strengthened. When you understand these sources, you kind of precisely know how confidence is built in someone brick-by-brick through the process of learning and environment and experiences.
你的意愿和渴望以特定方式展现自己。它与其说是你相信事情会进展顺利，不如说是你相信自己。它与其说是你相信人们会喜欢你，不如说是你相信任何超出你控制范围的东西。它是对你自己的信念。在我们变得自信之前，我们需要自我效能感。而自我效能感最棒的一点在于，它只能通过建设和努力来获得。它不能凭空被赋予我们。它不是在我们出生那一刻就存在或不存在的。因此，自我效能感的建立和增强主要有四个来源。当你了解了这些来源后，你就会确切地知道自信是如何通过学习、环境和经历的过程，在一块砖一块砖地在一个人身上建立起来的。
So the first source, the very first one, is something called mastery experiences or inactive attainments. Basically, when you successfully perform a task, especially one that you initially found rather challenging, it creates a belief in your capabilities. This starts from like three months old. Let's use the example of learning how to ride a bike because it's a very good one. You know, riding a bike is kind of scary. Like, it is kind of scary. Like, you have to balance on these two wheels and you can go really, really fast and you'll
所以第一个来源，最初的那个，叫做掌握经验或亲历成就。基本上，当你成功完成一项任务时，尤其是那些你最初觉得相当具有挑战性的任务时，它会建立起你对自己能力的信念。这从大约三个月大时就开始了。我们以学骑自行车为例，因为这是一个很好的例子。你知道，骑自行车有点可怕。是的，确实有点可怕。你需要在这个两个轮子上保持平衡，而且你可以骑得非常非常快，你可能
probably fall off. You know, the first few attempts involve wobbling and falling and that erodes your confidence. But with each kind of like successful pedal stroke, each moment of balance, like your belief and your ability to ride independently grows stronger, it's all based on these moments of feeling like, I didn't believe I could do this, but I can. and that for our mind kind of acts as these concrete data points that rewire your internal narrative. It rewires your trust in your own abilities. The fact that you've kind of, you are capable. Now the brain actively seeks and reinforces these positive experiences, which means
会摔下来。你知道，最初的几次尝试包括摇晃和摔倒，这会削弱你的自信。但随着每一次成功的蹬踏、每一个保持平衡的瞬间，你独立骑行的信念和能力就会变得更强，这一切都基于那些觉得“我原本以为自己做不到，但我确实做到了”的时刻。对于我们的大脑来说，这些时刻就像具体的数据库，重塑了你的内在叙事。它重塑了你对自己能力的信任。你是有能力的这一事实。现在，大脑会积极寻找并强化这些积极体验，这意味着
that the next time you encounter something scary or new, the judgment of others, the beginning of a new job, whatever it is, your brain kind of subconsciously looks, back at these prior moments and goes, actually know like we are fully capable of managing this. These moments of mastery can be deliberately created. And that's really important because the more times you show yourself through trial and error and through believing in yourself that you can do something, the more confident you will become. Next, we have vicarious experiences or social modeling.
下次你遇到可怕的或新鲜的事情时，比如别人的评判、新工作的开始，无论是什么，你的大脑都会潜意识地回顾过去的这些时刻，然后心想：其实我知道，我们完全有能力应对这一切。这些掌握的时刻是可以刻意创造的。这真的很重要，因为你通过试错和相信自己能做成某件事来向自己证明的次数越多，你就会变得越自信。接下来，我们有替代经验或社会建模。
We are, of course, inherently social beings and we learn a tremendous amount by simply observing others. When you see someone similar to yourself successfully perform a task that you want to do, it can significantly strengthen your belief that you also possess the capabilities to master similar activities. This is why mentors, role models, even peers are so crucial in building confidence. If you're a budding entrepreneur and you see someone from a similar background successfully launched their business, it sends a really powerful message. Like, if they can do it, maybe I can too. This actually really explains why representation matters and is so important for marginalized groups. There was a study done in 2016 in the UK, and researchers asked high-achieving
我们当然天生就是社会性动物，我们通过简单地观察他人就能学到大量东西。当你看到一个与你相似的人成功执行了你想做的事情时，它会大大增强你对“自己同样具备掌握类似活动能力”的信念。这就是为什么导师、榜样甚至同龄人在建立自信时如此至关重要。如果你是一个崭露头角的创业者，看到一个有着类似背景的人成功启动了他们的业务，这会发出一个非常强烈的信号。就像，如果他们能做到，也许我也行。这实际上很好地解释了为什么代表性至关重要，以及为什么对边缘化群体如此重要。2016年在英国进行过一项研究，研究人员要求来自代表性不足背景的高成就
university students from underrepresented backgrounds to basically send letters to students from similar backgrounds who were considering university and just talk about their experience, talk about the fact that it's possible. So there were over 11,000 people in this study. And these letters were really positive. They were like, shoot for the stars, you can do it, aim higher. And the researchers tracked students' application decisions and found that there was a significant increase in applications to more prestigious unies amongst the group that received the letters versus groups that did not. So this isn't about blind imitation.
大学生给考虑上大学的、来自相似背景的学生写信，谈论他们的经历，谈论一切皆有可能。这项研究中有超过11000人。这些信件非常积极。它们表达的意思是：志存高远，你能做到，把目标定得更高。研究人员追踪了学生的申请决定，发现与没有收到信件的群体相比，收到信件的群体向更知名大学提交申请的数量显著增加。所以这并非盲目模仿。
It's about seeing a pathway to success that is demonstrated by others, which then informs your own sense of possibility. It's also why I think that we could do with more admiration in this society. Instead of being jealous of people who have what you want or have the life that you want or who are doing better than you, these people can act as basically proof that your dreams, maybe aren't even that aren't big enough, because this person has managed to do it.
而是看到了一条由他人证明了的通往成功的道路，进而丰富了你自身的可能性感知。这也是为什么我认为在这个社会中我们其实可以有更多的赞美。与其嫉妒那些拥有你想要的东西、过着你想要的生活或者比你过得更好的人，不如把这些人当作证据，证明你的梦想甚至还不够宏大，因为这个人已经成功做到了。
Therefore, you can too. There is a pathway that is accessible. So confidence can be acquired through observation in a really significant way. The third way we gain self-efficacy is through social persuasion. So it's not observing someone else doing something. It's being encouraged by people who you admire. Having people like a coach, a parent, a teacher, a friend, someone that can say you're doing a good job. You are capable of doing this. Positive feedback, it's truly so motivational because we really
因此，你也可以。有一条你可以触及的道路。所以自信可以通过观察获得，这是一个非常重要的途径。我们获得自我效能感的第三种方式是通过社会说服。所以，这并不是观察别人做某事。而是受到你所钦佩的人的鼓励。拥有教练、父母、老师、朋友这样的人，他们会对你说：“你干得不错。你有能力做到这一点。”积极的反馈，真的极具动力，因为我们确实
do like external validation secretly, but also not secretly. And so if you have someone who you admire who was saying, like, wow, you really are getting better and you're improving and you're doing well, you're actually prepared to fail more. You're prepared to fail more, in some circumstances at least, because you have this weird desire within you to succeed more. And you kind of put yourself, you kind of face opportunities more often. You put yourself in the path for success more often, even though you know that failure might be a possibility, because you believe in yourself even in those moments when you do fail,
暗地里（其实也不算太暗地里）喜欢外部的认可。所以，如果你有一个你钦佩的人说：“哇，你真的在变好，你在进步，你做得很好，”你其实会准备好面对更多的失败。你在某种程度上至少会准备好接受失败，因为你内心有一种奇怪的渴望去取得更大的成功。并且你会把自己置于其中，你会更经常地面对机遇。你会更频繁地让自己走上成功之路，尽管你知道失败可能是一种可能，因为即使在你失败的那些时刻，你也相信自己，
because you have this strong sense of someone else believes in me despite missed opportunities, despite moments of ill confidence. therefore I can believe in myself. There's also the opposite, which is discouragement. Other people can really make us feel terrible about ourselves. From parents who are dismissive to childhood bullies, you know, I remember I had a teacher once who was really, really mean to me, and I was like, why do you have beef with me?
因为你有着强烈的信念：尽管有错失的机遇，尽管有缺乏自信的时刻，另一个人仍然相信我，因此我相信自己。当然，也有相反的情况，那就是打击。其他人确实会让我们对自己感觉糟糕。从冷漠的父母到童年的恶霸，你知道，我记得我以前有个老师对我很刻薄，我当时想：你对我有意见干嘛？
Like, I'm literally seven years old. And I felt really, like, I remember feeling really bad about myself and not wanting to try and not wanting to speak up. Discouragement is equally as powerful as encouraging. That is why it is so important to surround yourself with good people. It may be hard to go up against this if you've had a family who was really awful, or if you were bullied or if you do feel like your environment is really what made you the way you were and it's hard to escape.
我才七岁好吗。我当时真的觉得，我记得当时对自己感觉很糟糕，不想去尝试，也不想开口说话。打击和鼓励具有同样的威力。这就是为什么与优秀的人为伍如此重要。如果你有一个非常糟糕的家庭，或者如果你曾遭受霸凌，或者如果你真的觉得你的环境造就了现在的你而且很难逃脱，那要去对抗这些可能会很困难。
But the older you get, you do have choices to be around people who will care about you, who will elevate you, who will encourage you. you know, if your friends are secretly trying to tear you down, or if you are constantly listening to what people online are saying that is mean or cruel, if you let the words of your family members really invade your mindset, confidence it will be harder to obtain. Luckily, we have one final source of self-efficacy to talk about, and that's our ability to manage our own emotional reaction to stress. It's our physiological and emotional states.
但随着年龄的增长，你确实有选择去和那些关心你、提升你、鼓励你的人在一起。你知道，如果你的朋友暗地里试图贬低你，或者如果你一直在听信网络上那些刻薄或残忍的言论，如果你让家人的话语真正侵蚀你的心态，那么自信将更难获得。幸运的是，我们还有最后一个自我效能感的来源要谈，那就是我们管理自己对压力的情绪反应的能力。这是我们的生理和情绪状态。
Our mood, our stress levels, that can profoundly influence how we judge our potential for success. If you're feeling calm, energized and physically prepared for a task, you will believe in yourself more than if you went to bed super late or if you have had too much coffee or you're hungry. These choices matter and these are choices that you have control over. Basically, how you approach stress, how you learn to relate to your emotion. how you physically prepare yourself is a factor in whether you feel capable. But that also means that we can create routines and patterns and traditions that we know will make us feel confident and good
我们的情绪、压力水平，会深刻影响我们对自己成功潜力的判断。如果你感到平静、充满活力并为一项任务做好了身体上的准备，你就会比深夜才睡、喝了太多咖啡或饿着肚子时对自己更有信心。这些选择很重要，而这些是你能够控制的选择。基本上，你如何对待压力，你如何学会与自己的情绪建立联系。你如何做好身体上的准备，都是你是否觉得自己有能力的一个因素。但这也意味着我们可以建立一些我们知道能让自己感到自信和美好的日常习惯、模式和传统，
as a way to prepare us and counteract negative emotional states that kind of come with doing new things or being in front of new people. So when you understand these four sources, it becomes really clear, right, that confidence isn't an inherited trait. if you consistently seek out opportunities for mastery, if you observe others who are successful, if you go where you are valued, if you learn how to manage your anxiety and your physiological state, your self-efficacy and therefore your confidence will likely grow. It is important here to talk about the fact that although confidence isn't inherited,
以此作为准备并对冲那些伴随着做新事情或面对新面孔而产生的负面情绪状态的方法。所以，当你理解了这四个来源，就很清楚了，对吧，自信并不是一种遗传的特征。如果你持续寻找掌握的机会，如果你观察其他成功的人，如果你去到那些你被珍视的地方，如果你学会管理自己的焦虑和生理状态，你的自我效能感以及你的自信很可能会随之增长。这里有必要讨论这样一个事实：尽管自信不是遗传的，
it is, you know, really quite deeply influenced by how you were raised and who you grew up around. You know, if you, again, had parents who were deeply discouraging. If you grew up in poverty, if you grew up with, you know, mentors or teachers or no examples of success, you are starting from a harder point. And we have to be completely honest about that. It's not about ignoring those disadvantages. I would not be doing my job if I sat here and said, everyone starts from zero and starts at the same starting point. You know what I mean? And everyone has the equal ability to build confidence because it's just
但它确实，你知道，深受你的成长方式和身边人的深刻影响。你知道，如果你，再次强调，拥有极其打击你的父母。如果你在贫困中长大，如果你成长过程中，你知道，没有导师、没有老师，也没有成功的榜样，你的起点会更艰难。我们必须对此完全坦诚。这并不是要忽视那些劣势。如果我坐在这里说“每个人都从零开始，起点完全一样”，那我就是在玩忽职守。你知道我的意思吗？并不是每个人都有平等的建立自信的能力，因为事实根本
not the case. But what I'm really trying to say is that it is possible. So it's not like if you've had these experiences, you are completely doomed. If you have been raised to shrink yourself, to talk down to yourself, if you don't feel great about yourself, these are things that can actually be undone. They were done to you. That means that they have kind of like a counteracting or counterbalancing action that can also do upon you, that you can do upon yourself, not to reverse those things and to reverse those experiences, but to integrate them and say that you are more than them. We're going to talk a little bit more about that later on.
不是这样的。但我真正想表达的是，这是可能的。所以并不是说如果你有过这些经历，你就彻底完蛋了。如果你被教导要缩小自己、贬低自己，如果你对自己的感觉不太好，这些其实都是可以被逆转的。这些是别人对你做的事。这意味着它们有一种可以对你产生反作用或平衡作用的行为，你可以对自己这样做，不是为了逆转那些事情和经历，而是去接纳它们，并告诉自己你比它们更伟大。我们稍后会对此进行更多讨论。
But I think it's an important caveat to add here. Now that we kind of understand self-efficacy, let's also talk about how confidence is in part dictated by the conversation that you have with yourself. If you want to understand how you can make yourself believe that you are confident, you have to know the name Carol Dweck. She is a renowned Stanford psychologist, one of the best, who discovered that there are two and really only two fundamental mindsets. we can have regarding our intelligence and our abilities.
但我认为在这里补充这个限定条件很重要。既然我们已经了解了自我效能感，接下来我们也要谈谈自信在多大程度上是由你与自己的对话决定的。如果你想了解如何让自己相信自己是自信的，你必须知道卡罗尔·德韦克（Carol Dweck）这个名字。她是斯坦福大学的知名心理学家，也是最优秀的心理学家之一，她发现关于我们的智力和能力，存在着两种、且实际上只有两种基本的思维模式。
You've probably heard of them before. You can either have a fixed or a growth mindset. Someone with a fixed mindset believes that their basic abilities, their intelligence, their confidence. These are static traits. They are what they are. They were born that way. There's little that can be done to change them.
你可能以前听说过。你要么拥有固定型思维模式，要么拥有成长型思维模式。拥有固定型思维模式的人认为他们的基本能力、智力、自信，这些都是静态的特征。它们就是那样了。他们生来如此。几乎没有什么可以改变它们。
If you're good at math, it's because you were born being good at math. if you don't have confidence, it's because that's how you were born. There's nothing you can change. There's nothing you can do to change that. This kind of perspective is voluntary. I know it's going to sound harsh, but you do choose to believe that way. And so what that means is that when you face obstacles, when you face setbacks, when you look at your confidence levels and feel depleted by them, you don't feel like you can change them. You feel like you are always is going to be this way. In contrast, a person with a growth mindset believes in themselves,
如果你擅长数学，那是因为你生来就擅长数学。如果你缺乏自信，那是因为你生来就是这样的。没有什么你能改变的。没有什么你能做来改变这一点。这种观点是自愿的。我知道这听起来可能很严厉，但你确实选择了这种信仰方式。所以这意味着，当你面临障碍，当你面临挫折，当你审视自己的自信水平并为此感到精疲力竭时，你不会觉得你可以改变它们。你会觉得你永远都会是这个样子。相比之下，拥有成长型思维模式的人不仅相信自己，
but also believes that their most basic abilities can be developed through dedication and hard work and practice. And your brain, talent, personality, those are just starting points. In other words, they have what we call an internal locus of control. They believe in their ability to change their actions and therefore an outcome, but also to change their fate. Basically, when you believe, I am capable, I'm expanding, I am learning, I'm experiencing, I am confident, you act that way. You know that how you think about your situation and how you think about yourself will influence what parts of your, what parts of yourself grow and expand and what parts, you know, ultimately shrink. The reality, of course, is more.
而且相信他们最基本的能力可以通过奉献、努力和练习来不断发展。你的大脑、天赋、个性，都只是起点。换句话说，他们拥有我们所说的内部控制点。他们相信自己有能力改变自己的行动从而改变结果，同时也相信自己有能力改变命运。基本上，当你相信“我有能力，我在拓展，我在学习，我在体验，我很自信”时，你就会那样行事。你知道，你如何看待自己的处境以及你如何看待自己，将决定你身上的哪些部分、哪些自我特质会生长和拓展，而哪些部分，你知道，最终会萎缩。当然，现实要更加
nuanced. We've kind of already talked about this. You know, confidence is a skill. It is something that comes from mindset. It isn't something that you're born with, but there are other things that we are born into that can make it harder. What it's about discerning is really when your mindset can trump those things and when it cannot. And that's when having a formula for confidence or having skills and things in like your toolbox really helps. Because instead of just feeling power, paralyzed by situations. You do have options to try out to kind of counteract your lack of confidence, counteract your anxiety, counteract your social anxiety,
微妙。我们其实已经讨论过这一点了。你知道，自信是一种技能。它源于心态。它不是生来就有的，但有些我们生来所处的环境会使它变得更加困难。我们需要辨别的是，你的心态在什么时候能够战胜这些因素，在什么时候不能。这就是为什么拥有自信的公式，或者在你的“工具箱”里备好技能和方法会如此大有助益。因为你不再只是感到被权力剥夺、被现实瘫痪。你确实有选项去尝试，以此来对冲你缺乏自信、对冲你的焦虑、对冲你的社交焦虑，
counteract your imposter syndrome or your belief that you don't deserve to be there. So that really leads to the biggest question that we have today. How do we do that? I'm not just going to leave you guys here without some practical tips, including the formulas of some of the most confident people in the world, how you can walk into any room feeling amazing, unshaken, completely yourself. That's what we're going to explore after this short break.
对冲你的冒名顶替综合征，或者消除那种你觉得自己不配待在那里的信念。这确实引出了我们今天最大的问题。我们该如何做到这一点？我不会就这样把你们丢在这里而不提供一些实用的技巧，包括世界上最自信之人的某些秘诀，以及你如何能带着惊艳、沉稳、完全做自己的心态走进任何房间。这就是我们在短暂休息后将要探讨的内容。
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、体能和建立抗逆力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看透那些主导着健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾深信种子油本质上具有炎症性。
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-P-Cent on the I-Hart Radio. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终将成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方收听《2%》。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说小布希不关心黑人时。我知道你在想什么。
What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
小布希跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》（Look Back at It）播客中找到答案。我是山姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集中，我们都会挑选一个时刻，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何度过那段时期的。包括最近一期邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Marc Lamont Hill）做客，大谈80年代的快克可卡因。
To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
需要澄清的是，对84年我印象深刻，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备一整天都在谈论快克，只是为了让你们大家都知道。我的意思是，此时此刻，这是我们第二次讨论快克了。所以我开始看出这里有一条贯穿线。我们现在还把“艾滋病”摆在了桌面上。谢谢你把话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we,
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《回顾过去》。欢迎收听我的新播客《艰难成长的教训》，我是主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了致敬心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的丰富经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的深度对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐本身，以至于没有意识到我们，
are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth?
其实已经拥有了这件东西。但我们依然在追逐它。而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·布恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在人间做个好人很重要吗？
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood,
你成为一个好人是因为你心怀恐惧吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。这也是两种不同层次的信任。我希望你能真正地去做一个好人。和我基尔·盖恩斯一起，就疗愈、成长、为人父、
pressure, and personal. on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
压力和个人话题展开真实的对话。在我的新播客《艰难成长的教训》中。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索“Learn the Hard Way”并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的风暴中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了她言辞中明显的矛盾之处。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
这引发了一场长达数年的法庭之战，以证明真相。你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能看到他们的税款都被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian and Michael Maranini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues,
他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉尼尼。我的天呐。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困的爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，
Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Confidence is truly a mental game. And the good thing about that is that if you have the right mental strategies, you can bring
劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方收听《受困的爱》播客。自信确实是一场心理游戏。而这其中好的一点是，如果你掌握了正确的心理策略，你就可以把
these with you everywhere. You can apply them in any situation. If your brain's coming with you, these strategies are coming with you as well. So the first part of our mindset that we want to target are the deeper beliefs that we have that we don't deserve to be confident at all or that people will always be able to see through us. They will always see us as a fraud. They will always know we're faking it.
这些策略随身带到任何地方。你可以将它们应用于任何情况。如果你的大脑带在身上，这些策略也同样会带在身上。所以我们要针对的心理状态的第一部分，就是我们内心深处的那些信念：我们根本不配拥有自信，或者人们总能看穿我们。他们永远把我们看作骗子。他们永远知道我们在假装。
We call these thoughts, or at least I call them, confidence blockers. Your thoughts are powerful architects of your confidence and of your self-belief. So I do need you to become aware of your confidence blockers or your inner critics. What is your inner critic's favorite catchphrase and favorite thing to tell you when you're putting yourself out there or trying something new? Probably something along the lines of you can't do this. You're definitely going to mess it up. Everyone's going to know that you're a fraud. Everyone's going to see you fail.
我们称这些想法，或者至少我称之为，自信阻碍者。你的想法是你自信和自我信念的强大构建者。所以我确实需要你开始意识到你的自信阻碍者或你的内在批评者。当你在展现自我或尝试新事物时，你内在批评者最喜欢的口头禅和最喜欢对你说的话是什么？大概类似于：你做不到这个。你肯定会搞砸的。每个人都会知道你是个骗子。每个人都会看到你失败。
Not true, firstly. But when those self-defeating thoughts surface consciously pause. consciously pause, then begin to question them, is that thought truly 100% accurate? Like what concrete evidence do you actually have for that and what evidence do you have against it? You can fight back. You know, your inner critic isn't the only one with the voice. Your inner cheerleader also has something to say and they can say it louder. They can freaking scream it.
首先，这并不是真的。但当那些自我挫败的想法有意识地浮现时，请有意识地暂停。有意识地暂停，然后开始质疑它们：那个想法真的100%准确吗？比如，你究竟有什么具体的证据来支持它，你又有什么证据来反驳它？你可以反击。你知道，并不是只有你的内在批评者才有声音。你的内在拉拉队也有话要说，而且他们可以声音更大。他们可以放声尖叫。
You get to choose what you want to believe about the future. and about where you sit in the future because it hasn't happened yet. So as much as your inner critic wants you to believe that you're going to fail and you're going to embarrass yourself, it has no idea. It has no more idea than your inner cheerleader who thinks that you're going to do absolutely amazing. So every time you encounter a confidence blocker, I want you to repeat this mantra. Well, this series of mantras, I'm magnetic.
你可以选择你想要相信关于未来的什么，
People flock to me. My energy, it opens doors before I arrive. I move through this space, steady and prepared. I am calm. I am collected. I deserve to be here. I am confident. Any version of this, any series of phrases that supports you and elevates you and which
人们向我靠拢。我的能量，在我到达之前就打开了通往机遇的大门。我穿行于这个空间，坚定而准备就绪。我很冷静。我很镇定。我理应待在这里。我很自信。任何版本的咒语，任何一系列支持你、提升你、并且
capture you and, you know, enthrall you, I need you to be ready to kind of like throw them at your inner critic. I kind of think of it as like throwing balls of sunshine and like each time a ball of sunshine like hits your, like the shadow of your inner critic like it gets smaller and smaller and like parts of it like dissolve away whatever makes it visual for you. Positive self-talk like this is incredibly powerful. You and your brain have a two-way relationship. You are what you tell your brain. You become the words and the sayings that you speak to yourself. It's a process kind of loosely known as linguistic relativity. Basically the premise of this is that
能够吸引你、让你（你知道）着迷的短语，我需要你随时准备好用它们来对付你的内在批评者。我把这想象成扔出阳光之球，每次阳光之球击中内在批评者的阴影时，它就会变得越来越小，直到它的某些部分溶解消失，无论什么能让这个画面在你的脑海中具象化。诸如此类的积极自我对话具有难以置信的力量。你和你的大脑是一种双向关系。你就是你对大脑所说的话。你会变成那些你对自己说的话语和格言。这个过程粗略地被称为语言相对论。基本上，这个前提是：
the language that we use towards ourselves and towards the world doesn't just reflect what we're thinking. but actually shapes how we think. So if you are constantly using harsh or limiting language towards yourself, you may literally narrow how you see the world and how you see yourself within it. Conversely, if you use empowering language, confident language, open language, you broaden your sense of agency and you broaden your sense of the world. If you say to yourself, and sorry, I'm going to sound so repetitive here, but I promise I have a different point,
我们对自己和世界所使用的语言，不仅仅反映了我们的想法，实际上还塑造了我们的思考方式。因此，如果你总是对自己使用严厉或限制性的语言，你可能会字面意义上地缩小你看待世界的方式以及你在其中的自我定位。相反，如果你使用赋能的语言、自信的语言、开放的语言，你就会拓宽你的自主感和对世界的感知。如果你对自己说（抱歉，我在这里听起来会很重复，但我保证我有不同的观点），
If you say to yourself, I will succeed in this moment, I will be an image of confidence and power, that creates somewhat of a self-fulfilling prophecy, which we know is a psychologically proven and relevant concept because the expectations you set, especially through internal dialogue, influence your behavior in subliminal ways that often make your expectations come true. I also want you to sincerely ask yourself right now, why don't you deserve to be? confident. Let's put on our investigator hat for a second. Who convinced me that this is who I am? Who made me feel small? Who told me that I should shrink and that this is where I belong and I should be silent? And more importantly, what makes them right? Seriously, like, what evidence do they have? Are they like the head of some like accredited committee? Have they been ordained to be able to do this?
如果你对自己说：“此时此刻我必将成功，我将成为自信和力量的化身，”这会在某种程度上创造一种自我实现的预言，我们知道这是一个经心理学证明且相关的概念，因为你设定的期望，特别是通过内部对话设定的期望，会以潜移默化的方式影响你的行为，从而往往使你的期望成真。我还希望你现在真诚地问问自己：为什么你不配拥有自信？让我们戴上调查员的帽子一秒钟。是谁说服我这就是我的本性？是谁让我觉得自己很渺小？是谁告诉我应该退缩、这才是我的归宿、我应该保持沉默？更重要的是，是什么让他们觉得自以为是？说真的，比如，他们有什么证据？难道他们是什么经认证委员会的负责人吗？他们是被委任可以这么做吗？
Do they have some degree or some authority and who's allowed to be confident and who doesn't? No. They literally don't. They just have an opinion. And you can have a better opinion. You can have an opinion that's more accurate because you know yourself better than anyone. You know you're a good person. You know you're thoughtful.
他们有什么学位或权威吗？谁被允许自信，谁又不被允许？完全没有。他们根本没有。他们只是有观点。而你可以有更好的观点。你可以有更准确的观点，因为你比任何人都了解你自己。你知道你是个好人。你知道你很有心思。
You know you're smart. You know that you have things to say and that you deserve success. You know that better than anyone because you have to live with yourself every single day and they don't. So you can choose to disagree not only with your inner critic, but also with whoever it is, parent, family member, ex-boyfriend, ex-best friend who convinced you to be silent. Another incredible way to curate a confident mindset is through visualization. Visualization is so psychologically powerful. It's why we talk about it so much.
你知道你很聪明。你知道你有话要说，并且你值得成功。你比任何人都清楚这一点，因为你每天都必须和自己相处，而他们不用。所以你可以选择不仅与你的内心批判者意见相左，还可以与任何让你变得沉默的人意见相左，无论是父母、家庭成员、前男友还是前闺蜜。培养自信心态的另一个绝妙方法是通过可视化。可视化具有极强的心理威力。这就是为什么我们经常讨论它的原因。
Visualize how you want to enter a room before you enter it. and you will enter the room that way. Visualize how you want others to feel in your presence, and often they will feel that way. Visualize your voice being steady. Visualize the eye contact you'll make. Visualize your posture. Visualize your power.
在进入一个房间之前，先想象你将如何走进去，然后你就会那样走进去。想象你希望别人在你的陪伴下作何感想，通常他们就会那样去感受。想象你的声音很稳。想象你将进行的眼神交流。想象你的姿势。想象你的力量。
There are a few exercises to make this easier. One I have spoken about before, many times called the Golden Orb Theory. This is the one that I personally use. If you have ever met me at like a meetup or like on my book tour or at a live event, I promise you that I have been doing this when you have met me. This is what happens.
有几个练习可以让这变得更容易。我以前多次讲过其中一个，叫做“金球理论”。这是我个人使用的方法。如果你曾在某次聚会上见过我，或者在我的新书巡回签售会上，或者在某个现场活动中见过我，我向你保证，当你见到我时，我一直在这样做。事情是这样的。
I, before I enter into any room, I feel this nice golden orb in my heart. Obviously it's not there. We're visualising, but I imagine there is this like pulsating, beautiful ball of light. And every time I breathe in and breathe out as I step into this room, it expands and expands and expands. Anytime I make eye contact with someone and have a conversation, that fuels it even more. And this ball, this orb just gets bigger and bigger and bigger so that
在我进入任何房间之前，我都能感受到心脏里有一个美好的金球。显然它并不在那里。我们在进行可视化，但我能想象有这样一个脉动的、美丽的微光球体。每当我吸气并呼气，当我步入这个房间时，它就在不断地膨胀、膨胀、再膨胀。每当我与某人进行眼神交流并交谈时，都会给它注入更多的能量。这个球体，这个光球就会变得越来越大，越来越大，以至于
anyone it touches, anyone who comes into contact with it immediately feels comfortable, immediately feels tired to me, immediately feels, you know, good around me, immediately feels like their best self and I feel like my best self. And it's this visual way of imagining that I get to control how other people are feeling. Obviously, I don't, but I do get to control my own perception of their feelings. And I know that sounds strange, but often with social anxiety or not feeling confident, it's not that you don't know that you can handle yourself. It's that you're overly worried with how other people are going to perceive you. So if you give yourself the illusion that you can change their perception, suddenly nothing else really matters and you feel
任何接触到它的人，任何与它接触的人都会立刻感到舒适，立刻对我有亲切感，立刻觉得，你知道的，在我身边感觉很好，立刻觉得他们展现出了最好的自己，而我也觉得自己展现出了最好的自己。这是一种直观的想象方式，让我能够控制别人的感受。显然，我并不能控制，但我确实可以控制自己对他们感受的看法。我知道这听起来很奇怪，但通常对于社交焦虑或缺乏自信而言，并不是因为你觉得自己无法应付，而是因为你过于担心别人会如何看待你。因此，如果你给自己一种可以改变他们看法的幻觉，突然之间其他一切都不重要了，你就会感到
the ability to be authentic and natural. And that's what this kind of activity and exercise really does for me. There's another one. It's known as the golden thread trick, golden orb theory, golden thread trick. You're seeing a theme. Basically, it's about imagining like a golden thread pulling from the top of your head into the sky. Instead of controlling you, it's elevating you. And it's making sure that you take up space. It's not going to let you slouch. It's not going to let you shrink. It wants you to be present. And you have like the permission from this golden string, this thing way up high going into the cosmos and beyond to be here and to be strong. You're drawing all of your power from it.
一种展现真实和自然自我的能力。这就是这类活动和练习真正带给我的作用。还有另一个方法。它被称为金线把戏，金球理论，金线把戏。你看出规律了吧。基本上，它是关于想象有一根金线从你的头顶拉向天空。它不是在控制你，而是在提升你。它确保你能占据空间。它不会让你驼背。它不会让你畏缩。它希望你活在当下。你得到了这根金丝的允许，这根通往宇宙及更远处的神秘高物，让你留在这里并变得强大。你正在从中汲取你所有的力量。
There's also the very famous act as if technique. The act as if technique, it's a psychological strategy that involves behaving as if you already are the version of yourself you want to become. Confident, secure, successful, grounded, you are already those things, even if you don't fully feel it yet. we talked about modeling before and modeling really asks you to look at someone else who has what you have and to kind of emulate them. You can also kind of emulate yourself as well, right? Like you can emulate a version of yourself that you think is incredible and who you want to become and who you can so
还有一个非常著名的“假装”技巧。“假装”技巧是一种心理策略，它包括表现得好像你已经成为了你想成为的那种版本的自己。自信、安全、成功、脚踏实地，你已经是这些了，即使你现在还没有完全感受到。我们之前讨论过建模，建模实际上要求你看看拥有你所拥有之物的人，并去效仿他们。你也可以在某种程度上效仿你自己，对吧？就像你可以效仿一个你认为非常了不起的自己，一个你想成为的自己，一个你能如此
clearly visualize. It's not about faking it. It's about rehearsing the reality that you're stepping into. And over time, the gap between who you are and who you're actually. as if begins to close and so you feel like that version of you is real. It's like method acting almost, method acting for a future version of you that you want to become. Also not to bring up modeling again, but if it's too hard to fake it, you don't have to. You can also borrow your confidence. You can borrow other people's innate abilities. Like you can borrow their sense of satisfaction and pride in themselves. When you see, see someone that you really admire. Think about the coolest person you know, like the coolest,
清晰地想象出来的自己。这并不是假装。这是在彩排你正在迈入的现实。随着时间的推移，你是谁与你实际上正在扮演的“假装”之间的差距开始缩小，于是你会觉得那个版本的自己是真实的。这几乎就像方法派演技，为你想要成为的未来版本的自己进行方法派演技。另外，并不是要再次提起建模，但如果假装太难，你也不必非得这么做。你还可以借用你的自信。你可以借用其他人与生俱来的能力。比如你可以借用他们对自己的满足感和自豪感。当你看到、看到一个你真正钦佩的人时。想想你认识的最酷的人，比如最酷、
most ambitious, amazing person, aspirational person you know, think about everything that they would do in this situation that you're scared to be in. How would they hold themselves? How would they walk in? How would they speak? How would they communicate? How would they be? Think about that. Take it all and pretend that that's you. Borrow what they have. There was a study that I read from 2021 that actually looked at how this is used to help train the confidence of young Olympic athletes or Olympic hopefuls. And there was a study done in Korea. And the researchers basically asked their participants who were people who would probably one day be in the Olympics to borrow their confidence from someone they admired. They were paired with an older team member or an older Olympic hopeful or an
最有抱负、最了不起的人，你所知道的那个激励人心的人，想想他们在你现在害怕面对的这种情况下会怎么做。他们会如何保持仪态？他们会如何走进来？他们会如何说话？他们会如何沟通？他们会是怎样的状态？想想看。把这一切都吸收进来，假装那就是你。借用他们所拥有的。我读过2021年的一项研究，该研究实际探讨了如何利用这一点来帮助培养年轻奥运选手或奥运会预备役选手的自信。韩国曾做过一项研究。研究人员基本上要求他们的参与者（这些参与者很可能是未来某天会参加奥运会的人）向他们钦佩的人借用自信。他们与年长的队员或年长的奥运会预备役人员，甚至是一
an Olympian even at that. And they were asked to think about them before they were. they, you know, started swimming or dove off the diving board or did whatever sport they were doing. Think about them. Think about what they would do. Think about how they would stand. And their self-efficacy, which we know as a crucial ingredient, increased. Not only did their self-efficacy increase, they were also better able to really shift into a flow state. They were better able to cut through the noise of their own insecurity or their lack of self-belief and just be present in what they were doing. So just choose someone you admire, borrow what they have. Another step to mastering confidence and really building this skill like a muscle is putting yourself in situations where you can prove to yourself, you can cope.
甚至还是一位奥运选手。他们被要求在开始游泳、从跳板上跳下或进行他们所从事的任何运动之前，先想象这些选手。想象他们，想象他们会怎么做，想象他们会如何站立。我们知道自我效能感是至关重要的要素，而他们的自我效能感增强了。不仅他们的自我效能感增强了，他们还能更好地真正进入心流状态。他们能够更好地排除自身不安全感或缺乏自信的干扰，专注于他们正在做的事情。所以，只需选择一个你崇拜的人，借用他们的特质。掌握自信并真正像锻炼肌肉一样培养这种技能的另一个步骤，是将自己置于能够向自己证明你能够应对的环境中。
You can win, you can show up, you can be successful, basically find ways to experience small boost to your confidence, like those mastery experiences we were talking about before. A lot of building confidence is actually exposure, like anything. if you have a social phobia, like how they treat most phobias as exposure. So if you have a social phobia or any kind of anxiety around specifically being around people, what someone is probably going to ask you, what a therapist is probably going to get you to do is to be in those spaces that terrify you the most as much as possible. If you are terrified of dating, you have to go on 10 first dates to win the challenge.
你可以获胜，你可以挺身而出，你可以成功，基本上就是找到方法让你的自信心得到微小的提升，就像我们之前讨论过的那些精通体验一样。建立自信很大程度上其实是暴露疗法，就像任何事情一样。如果你有社交恐惧症，就像他们如何治疗大多数恐惧症一样，那就是暴露。因此，如果你有社交恐惧症或对身处人群中有任何形式的焦虑，别人可能会要求你做的事，治疗师可能会让你做的事，就是尽可能多地置身于那些让你感到最恐惧的空间里。如果你害怕约会，为了赢得挑战，你必须去进行10次第一次约会。
If you're scared of meeting strangers, you have to go to all these stranger events. If you're scared of giving presentations, you have to volunteer to do them. No skill ever is built simply by thinking about it. It's built through practice. It's built through stretching, pushing yourself. And you know what? That's really scary. It's really freaking scary.
如果你害怕遇到陌生人，你就必须去参加所有这些陌生人活动。如果你害怕做演讲，你就必须主动报名去做。没有任何技能是通过仅仅思考就能建立起来的。它是通过实践建立起来的。它是通过伸展、挑战自我建立起来的。你知道吗？这真的很可怕。这真的他妈的好可怕。
It's also the only way to do it. I'm sorry to say. And then one day, not too long in the future, you'll suddenly find yourself being the person who is no longer at the beginning of this story, but, you know, halfway through it, who was able to turn around and say, I used to be someone who really struggled with this. I used to be someone who didn't want to date, who didn't want to put myself out there, who didn't want to wear these clothes. And now I'm a success story because I put in the work.
这也是唯一的做法。我很抱歉这么说。然后有一天，在不久的将来，你突然会发现自己成了这样一个人：你不再是这个故事开端时的人，而是，你知道的，走到了故事的一半，那个能够回过头来说：“我曾经是一个为此苦苦挣扎的人。我曾经是一个不想约会、不想展现自我、不想穿这些衣服的人。而现在，我是一个成功的故事，因为我付出了努力。”
Finally, really consciously focus on your sphere of control. This is like the practical everyday application of cultivating a growth mindset and a strong locus of control. When you find yourself facing a challenge or a daunting situation or decision, you have to really ask yourself, what parts of this can I genuinely do something about? And what parts do I just have to accept or lean into? Then, critically direct your energy and your effort solely towards the things you can influence, your preparation, your effort, your belief, your learning, your attitude, how you choose to adapt, rather than wasting precious time and energy on things that are never going to be something you can change even if you
最后，真正有意识地关注你的控制圈。这是培养成长型心态和强烈的控制点的实用日常应用。当你发现自己面临挑战、令人生畏的情况或决定时，你必须真正问自己：关于这件事，我有哪些部分是真的可以做点什么的？哪些部分是我只能接受或顺其自然的？然后，将你的能量和努力批判性地全部投入到你能影响的事情上，比如你的准备、你的努力、你的信念、你的学习、你的态度、你选择如何适应，而不是把宝贵的时间和精力浪费在那些无论你如何
try your hardest. One huge example of something you can't control, and this might surprise you, it's what other people choose to think of you. You may be thinking like, oh wait, what the heck? Isn't that all we've been talking about, like all those exercises that you just told us, like wasn't that to control or influence what other people think? No, those aren't meant to change what they think. They're meant to change what you think. They're meant to change how you think about yourself. That is way more powerful than ever trying to change or other people think of you. They're going to follow your example. How you think about yourself is how other people will often end up thinking about you. People can have whatever opinions they want as well. That's also not your business. You just can't control it.
竭尽全力也永远无法改变的事情上。你无法控制的一件大事，这可能会让你感到惊讶，那就是别人对你的看法。你可能会想：等等，搞什么鬼？这难道不是我们一直在谈论的吗，比如你刚才告诉我们的所有那些练习，难道不是为了控制或影响别人的想法吗？不，那些并不是为了改变他们的想法。它们是为了改变你的想法。它们是为了改变你对自己的看法。这比试图改变或左右别人对你的看法要强大得多。他们会效仿你的榜样。你如何看待自己，往往就是别人最终如何看待你。别人也可以有他们想要的任何意见。那也不是你的事。你只是无法控制。
and you will go mad trying to because trust me there will always be someone who has negative thoughts about everyone no matter who they are. I think we've all been on the internet long enough to know this, right? You know, literally think about like the coolest person on this planet, like the most confident, successful, talented person. I can tell you right now, there is someone out there who doesn't like that person. There is someone out there who could sit down with this person and have a big in-depth conversation and still not like them. If confidence only came from people liking you, no one would ever be confident because everyone,
你会因为试图控制而发疯，因为相信我，无论谁是谁，总会有人对所有人抱有负面看法。我想我们在互联网上待的时间足够长，都知道这一点了吧，对吧？你知道的，字面意思上想想这个星球上最酷的人，比如最自信、最成功、最有才华的人。我现在就可以告诉你，总会有人不喜欢那个人。总会有人可以坐下来与这个人进行深入的长谈，却依然不喜欢他们。如果自信仅仅来自于别人喜欢你，那就没有人会自信了，因为每个人，
there is a hater for everyone out there. So instead of fighting against this like immovable brick wall that is someone else's nasty thoughts, focus on how you feel, what do you want from a situation, how do you want to leave feeling? Remember, people that are confident, they're not these like shiny, perfect, great at everything,
在这个世界上，每个人都有讨厌他所以，与其与这堵不可动摇的、别人的讨厌想法构成的砖墙作斗争，不如专注于你的感受：你从一种情况中想要什么？你想要带着什么样的感受离开？记住，自信的人，他们不是那种光芒四射、完美无缺、做什么都厉害的人。
people. They are often people who can admit when they're not great at things. They can ask for help. They also know that there will be people who don't like them, but they know what's in their control, which is their mindset. Okay, we are going to take another short break, but when we return, I have some listener questions, some listener dilemmas, all about confidence. So please stay with us. We will be right back after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
他们往往是能够承认自己并非在所有事情上都很厉害的人。他们可以寻求帮助。他们也知道会有人不喜欢他们，但他们知道什么在他们的掌控之中，那就是他们的心态。好了，我们要进行短暂的休息，但当我们回来时，我有一些听众的问题，一些听众的困惑，全部都关于自信。所以请继续收听我们的节目。稍事休息后，我们马上回来。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇异现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和韧性的科学。
I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的。听听《2%》。那是I-Heart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的T-W-O-Persent。
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是山姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of Congress. crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
其中包括最近一期有马克·拉蒙特·希尔做客的节目，他滔滔不绝地讲述了80年代的快克可卡因。坦白说，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅因为国会议员。快克。我随时准备在节目里聊聊快克，不过就是让大家知道。我的意思是，此时此刻，这是我们讨论快克的第二期节目。所以我开始看出一条贯穿始终的主线了。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上讨论了。
Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your Podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast,
谢谢你把那句话说完。我不认为还有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。请在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎收听我的新播客，
Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking.
《艰难险阻》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的丰富经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。
Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时候，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这件东西。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on Earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines,
史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在地球上做个好人很重要？你做个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是的。这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能够真正地去做一个好人。和我基尔·盖恩斯一起，
as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
在我的新播客《艰难险阻》中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的爱心电台应用程序。搜索“Learn the Hard Way”并立即收听。2023年，前“单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场历时多年的法庭之战来证明真相。
You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, the lesbian, Michael Marantini.
你对某人伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的税金被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，莱斯利，迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is. served in Arizona.
我的天哪，太震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈罪被起诉。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome back, everybody. We have some listener questions coming straight from you guys, obviously, the listeners. If you want to be able to partake in this section of the podcast, make sure you are following us at that psychology podcast over on Instagram so that you can see when I put up question boxes for new. episodes. Questions for this week? So good. Thank you guys for coming out with your question hats on.
请在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。欢迎回来，各位。我们有一些听众的问题直接来自于你们，也就是听众们。如果你想参与到播客的这个环节中，请确保你在Instagram上关注了“that psychology podcast”，这样你就可以看到我在什么时候为新节目发布了问题箱。这周的问题？太棒了。谢谢你们带着问题帽子来参加。
Wow, I sound like, I sound like a school teacher. But yes, thank you for asking some really cool, interesting things. Let's get into it. This question, in some form or another, was probably the most asked question. I really struggled that if I'm too confident, I will come off as cocky in work situations and beyond. Where is the line? So many of you wanted to know, know this. Where is the line between being confident and arrogant or coming off as a jerk? Such a great question. I think the fact that you are already aware of this possibility means that you are probably self-correcting too much because you're so conscious of it, which could actually be having the opposite effect of meaning you're shrinking yourself more than you deserve to. We want to find
哇，听起来我像个学校老师。但是，是的，谢谢你们提出一些非常酷、有趣的问题。让我们切入正题。这个问题，以某种形式出现，可能是被问得最多的。我真的纠结于：如果我太自信了，在工作场合及其他地方，我会显得很自傲。这条界限在哪里？你们当中有很多人想知道答案。自信与傲慢之间，或者说显得像个混蛋之间的界限在哪里？这是一个太好的问题了。我认为你已经意识到这种可能性，这就意味着你可能因为太在意而矫枉过正了，这实际上可能会产生相反的效果，让你比你应得的更加自我收敛。我们想要找到
an authentic way of expressing confidence, right? And so what's important to notice is how you're really feeling in yourself. Don't think about others for a second. When you are truly confident, you probably feel very calm, you feel alert, you feel grounded. When you are feeling arrogant, you feel tense, you feel anxious, you feel like you have something to prove, you feel forceful. Learn to tell the two apart and to just stay in the first lane. When you are authentically confident, that comes off amazingly. When you feel grounded, it comes off amazingly. When you are anxious is when you actually end up being arrogant. So as long as you can tell the difference, I think you're pretty safe. I will also say I hate the word cocky, especially when it's used
一种表达自信的真实方式，对吧？所以需要注意的是你内心的真实感受。先不要去想别人。当你真正自信时，你可能会感到非常平静，你会感到警觉，你会感到脚踏实地。当你感到傲慢时，你会感到紧张，你会感到焦虑，你会觉得自己有什么要证明的，你会感到咄咄逼人。学会区分这两者，并只停留在第一条轨道上。当你真正自信时，效果会好得惊人。当你感到踏实时，效果会好得惊人。当你感到焦虑时，你最终才会表现得傲慢。所以只要你能分清区别，我认为你就很安全。我也想说，我讨厌“自傲”这个词，尤其是当它被用来
towards others to put them down. Like there are very, very, very few people who are genuinely arrogant and cocky. And yet people use that word to really keep other people small because it benefits them to do so or because they think that they should get to being control of how people act when it's not of their business. Often it is just a projection. of how they think they themselves should act and therefore how everyone else should act because they've chosen to do it. But they don't really get to make the rules. No one does. Worry less about being seen as cocky and more about what feels right for you to share, what feels right for you to open up about what you want to say, how you want to act,
贬低别人时。因为真正傲慢自傲的人非常、非常、非常少。然而人们却用这个词来把其他人贬得很小，因为这样做对他们有利，或者因为他们认为自己应该去控制别人的行为，而这根本不管他们的事。这通常只是一种投射。投射出他们认为自己应该如何行事，因此每个人也都该如何行事，因为他们自己选择了这样做。但他们其实并没有资格制定规则。没有人可以。少担心被视为自傲，多关注什么对你来说分享起来是对的，什么对你来说敞开心扉谈论你想要说的话、你想要的行为是正确的，
how you feel in a situation. If you feel strong and powerful, if you don't doubt yourself or question yourself and say things that genuinely feel true and meaningful, that is the coming from a deep place. And if someone interprets that as cocky, you know that it's not your intention. And that's really the only explanation you need. Basically, if you're worried about coming off as arrogant or conceded, you are actually the person that I'd probably be worried least about because you have self-awareness and I don't think that truly arrogant people do. So you should be okay. Second question, another freaking banger. Why do we feel less confident in a group of very confident people. I think there are a few explanations. Maybe, I think firstly, it feels like there's probably
你在某种情况下的感觉如何。如果你感到坚强和充满力量，如果你不自我怀疑或质疑自己，并说出真正真实和有意义的话，那是发自内心的深处。如果有人将此解读为自傲，你知道这不是你的初衷。这真的是你唯一需要的解释。基本上，如果你担心自己显得傲慢或自负，你其实是我最不用担心的人，因为你有自我意识，而我认为真正的傲慢之人是没有的。所以你应该没事的。第二个问题，又是一个他妈的爆款问题。为什么在一群非常自信的人中间，我们会感到不那么自信？我认为有几个解释。也许，我认为首先，感觉好像
less space to take up, less kind of like breathing room, because everyone is like really demanding and asking for airtime, probably also triggers a little bit of imposter syndrome. Like, these people have real reasons to be confident. Like these people really look like they believe in themselves. I don't. I'm just a fraud. Their confidence seems organic. Mine feels fake. That's one take. let's also talk about a more neurobiological side to things, which is a bit more complex, but we often, I think, feel less confident in groups of highly confident people, not just because of imposter syndrome, but also because of dominance hierarchies. You know, we are deeply social animals that's encoded into our neurobiology.
可以占用的空间更少了，呼吸的空间也更少了，因为每个人都在真正地要求和争取发言时间，这可能也会触发一点点冒名顶替综合症。就像：这些人有真正的理由自信。这些人看起来真的对自己很有信心。而我没有。我只是个骗子。他们的自信看起来是自发的。我的感觉是假的。这是一种看法。让我们也谈谈更偏向神经生物学的一面，这会稍微复杂一些，但我们经常，我认为，在一群高度自信的人中间感到不那么自信，不仅是因为冒名顶替综合症，也是因为支配等级。你知道，我们是深度社会化的动物，这已经编码在我们的神经生物学中。
And from an evolutionary standpoint, entering a group meant having to be able to subconsciously assess where we sat in the social order. So like who's dominant, who's subordinate, who's safe to align with who feels like a friend, high confidence and high confident people signal dominance through their tone, their posture, their speech, they feel like they are leaders. And so our brain has to readjust where we sit. And that may interpret things as a challenge to our social standing, even if it's not, because we have these ancient brains in a modern setting. You know, there isn't just one person who's always in charge. There isn't just one leader who will dominate over others, there is more space. The important thing to also remember is that truly confident people,
从进化的角度来看，进入一个群体意味着必须能够在潜意识中评估我们在社会秩序中所处的位置。比如谁是主导者，谁是服从者，和谁结盟是安全的，谁感觉像朋友。高度自信和高度自信的人通过他们的语调、姿势、言谈发出支配的信号，他们感觉自己就像领导者。所以我们的大脑必须重新调整我们所处的位置。这可能会将事情解释为对我们社会地位的挑战，即使事实并非如此，因为我们在现代环境中拥有这些古老的大脑。你知道，并不是只有一个人永远在发号施令。并不是只有一个领导者会压倒其他人，这里有更多的空间。同样需要记住的重要一点是，真正自信的人，
they are the ones who want others to thrive and they want to elevate you. Confident people have actually been shown to judge others less and they spend more time assessing themselves compared to other people. So actually, in a room full of confident people, you are probably the safest you will ever be from judgment. So actually, this is where you should feel free to be loud, take risk, tell stories, be who you want to be authentically. If they judge you, that's something they have to address, not you. Next question, does being delusional actually help in elevating confidence? 100%. Yes, yes, yes.
他们才是那些希望别人繁荣并想要提升你的人。事实证明，自信的人实际上更少评判他人，他们花更多的时间评估自己而不是与他人进行比较。所以实际上，在一个充满自信的人的房间里，你可能是最安全的，远离评判。所以实际上，在这里你应该感到自由，可以大声说话、承担风险、讲故事、真实地做你自己。如果他们评判你，那是他们需要解决的事情，而不是你。下一个问题，妄想真的能帮助提升自信吗？百分之百。是的，是的，是的。
Being delusional can make you more confident. It's again, the language and the way that you're speaking to yourself. It relates to that self-fulfilling prophecy that we kind of talked about before. if you, you know, feel like you can be something, if you just so deeply believe it, chances are that you're more likely to act in a way that will make that happen. Kind of relating to the first question, though, there is a fine line here between delusion and narcissism and also delusion and actually putting in the work. Like, confidence is a skill, not a trait.
妄想能让你更自信。这还是关于语言和对自我说话的方式。它与我们之前讨论过的那个自证预言有关。如果你，你知道的，觉得自己可以成为某种人，如果你只是如此深信不疑，那么你更有可能以一种能让之成真的方式去行动。不过，结合第一个问题来看，这里在妄想与自恋之间，以及在妄想与真正付出努力之间，存在着一条微妙的界限。就像自信是一种技能，而不是一种特质。
That's the title of the episode. Skills require work. So saying like, this is going to happen to me. me, this is going to happen for me, all great things. You should believe in yourself. You should believe in your dreams. You also have to do something about them. You also have to find a way to take all of that really positive energy. Like that's a great starting point and make a plan, be willing to initiate, be willing to put yourself out there. Be willing to be cringe, embarrassing, fail. That's what a really confident person would do. But yes, being delusional, 100% very helpful. Final question.
这就是本集的标题。技能需要付出努力。所以说，这会发生在我身上，这会为我发生，这些都是极好的事情。你应该相信自己。你应该相信你的梦想。你也必须为此做点什么。你也必须找到一种方法，把所有这些非常积极的能量——这是一个很好的起点——转化为一个制定计划的行动，愿意主动出击，愿意把自己展现出去。愿意感到尴尬、出丑、失败。这才是真正自信的人会做的事。但是，是的，妄想，百分之百非常有用。最后一个问题。
How do I feel confident in a physical feature I can't change? I don't want to get surgery slash I can't. So how do I embrace, if not truly learn to love this part of me? I really relate to this. Yeah, I really relate to this for a long time. There are things about myself that I really wanted to change. I still do. Here's the thing.
我该如何对一个无法改变的身体特征感到自信呢？我不想做手术，或者我做不了。那么，我该如何拥抱，如果不是真正学会爱我身上的这一部分的话？我真的很有共鸣。是的，我对此真的很有共鸣，持续了很长一段时间。我身上有些东西是我真的很想改变的。现在还是这样。事情是这样的。
We were not meant to be as conscious of our appearance as we are. appearance was not meant to be such an important factor as it is in modern society. And so of course it's really hard to love yourself when the thing a lot of us feel judged for first and foremost is by our looks. And it's not just that looks signal attractiveness anymore or fertility or whatever it was meant to. It signals wealth and it signals social standing and it signals all these other things that it's just like making it such a confusing thing to manage. oh my God, I saw this video the other day and not to judge this woman at all, but I saw this video of
我们本来就不应该对自己的外表像现在这样斤斤计较。外表本不该成为现代社会中如此重要的一个因素。所以，当许多人首先因为外表而受到评判时，你很难去爱自己，这当然是理所当然的。而且这不仅意味着外表代表着吸引力、生育能力或它原本意味着的任何东西。它代表着财富，代表着社会地位，还代表着所有其他事情，这让管理它变得如此令人困惑。天哪，我前几天看到一个视频，绝对没有要评判这位女性的意思，但我看到这个视频讲的是
this woman who had sperm, like, what was it? Um, like fish sperm injected into her face. And I was like, that, imagine telling someone like 6,000 years ago that that was something that was done. Like, that sounds like medieval torture. And yet that's like something that people pay for to like stay young these days. And, um, it's just the culture that we live in. No wonder everyone feels ugly. Like, I don't know anyone who truly just feels beautiful in themselves anymore. There's always something that an industry or a business or a brand is going to try and make you feel insecure about. So it's worth asking yourself, who taught me that this was a problem in the first place and what do they have to gain from making me feel bad? Often, you know, our discomfort is a mirror reflecting society's very narrow ideals.
一个女人把精液，什么来着？嗯，就像鱼精一样的东西注射到她的脸里。当时我就想，想象一下在六千年前告诉别人这是会做的事。听起来就像中世纪的酷刑。然而，这却是现在人们为了保持年轻而花钱去做的东西，而且，这就是我们生活的文化。难怪每个人都觉得自己丑。我是说，我不知道现在还有谁能真正觉得自己很美。总会有某个行业、某家企业或某个品牌试图让你对自己的外表感到不安全。所以值得问问自己：到底是谁一开始教会了我这是一个问题？他们让我感觉糟糕有什么好处呢？通常，你知道的，我们的不适感是一面镜子，折射出社会非常狭隘的审美标准。
It's not an objective truth. ugliness is actually not objective at all. Also just really start by softening the language. Shift from ugly to unusual to unique to special, from embarrassing to mine to whatever word you want to use that feels firstly neutral and then positive. You don't have to force yourself to love yourself right away. Aim for neutrality. Aim for something that's a little bit easier and just saying this part of me,
这并不是客观真理。丑陋其实一点也不客观。另外，真的可以从软化语言开始。把“丑陋”转变为“与众不同”，转变为“独特”、转变为“特别”，把“尴尬”转变为“属于我的”或者任何你想用的词，只要它先让人感觉中性，然后感觉积极。你不必强迫自己立刻去爱自己。以保持中立为目标。以稍微容易一点的目标开始，只要说我身上的这一部分，
it exists, I don't need to shrink because of it. Also, how you look is really the least interesting thing about you. And I know I've said that so often and I'm sorry if you've heard it before, but if life was all about appearances, it would be very boring. And beauty does fade and beauty becomes something that people can only talk about for so long. So focus on the other areas of your life where you feel naturally confident and work on expanding them, work on thinking about them more, putting more time into those areas, celebrating them. Beauty and attractiveness, it is something we all live with, obviously, and have to consider, and we exist in a system where that does matter.
它存在，我不需要为此而畏缩。另外，你的外表其实是你身上最不重要的特征。我知道我经常这么说，如果你以前听过的话我很抱歉，但如果生活全都是外表的话，那就太无趣了。美貌会消逝，美貌也只能成为人们谈论一时的话题。所以，把注意力集中在你生活中那些能让你感到自然自信的其他领域，并努力扩展它们，努力多去思考它们，花更多时间在这些领域上，去庆祝它们。美貌和吸引力，这是我们所有人都与之共存的，显然也是必须考虑的，我们生活在一个外表确实重要的体系中。
I'm not going to deny it. But how much do you want it to matter? How much do you want it to dictate the rest of your life? That's like a big question that I think is very existential and that you kind of have to answer for yourself. But I wish you the best of luck and know that I'm there with you. and I've had many a similar thought. That is all we have time for today, my lovely listeners.
我不会否认这一点。但你希望它有多重要？你希望它决定你的余生到什么程度？这是一个很大的问题，我认为这是非常存在主义的，你必须为自己找到答案。但我祝你一切顺利，并请知道我和你在一起。我也曾有过许多类似的想法。亲爱的听众们，今天我们的时间就到这里了。
I hope that this episode has given you something to think about and given you something to apply to your own life. I hope you know confidence is a skill, not a trait. And with a skill, with any skill, it's something that you can improve in whatever area of your life you want to feel more like yourself and more for yourself. Leave your most like unhinged confidence tips in the comments below if you have one that I haven't mentioned, let's share it.
我希望这一集能给你们带来一些启发，并能应用到你们自己的生活中。我希望你们知道，自信是一种技能，而不是一种特质。而对于一种技能，任何技能，在你想让自己感觉更像自己、为了自己活得更好的任何生活领域中，它都是你可以提升的东西。如果你有什么我没有提到的绝招，请在下面的评论中留下你最疯狂的自信秘诀，让我们一起来分享吧。
What's the thing that you do that is just so weird and wacky but always works and always makes you feel amazing, whether it's like a playlist, whether it's like whatever it is, like what is it? I want to know. Make sure again, you are following me on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast and let you share this episode with a friend, with a family member, with a colleague who you think could benefit from listening to it. Follow, subscribe, like, share, all those things.
你做过什么事情，是那种极其怪异古怪但却总是管用，总是能让你感觉棒极了的？不管是一个播放列表，还是别的什么东西，到底是什么？我想知道。再次提醒，一定要在Instagram上关注我@That Psychology Podcast，并把这一集分享给你的朋友、家人、同事，你认为他们听了会有所收益的人。关注、订阅、点赞、分享，所有这些。
get which order they're in, but you know the deal. It really helps the show grow. It helps it reach new people. Also, puts a smile on my face if that's something you may or may not want to do. But anyways, until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle with yourself. We will talk very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
我记不清它们的顺序了，但你们懂的。这真的对节目的成长很有帮助。它能帮助节目接触到新的人群。如果你想这么做或者不想这么做的话，这也给我的脸上带来了一个微笑。不管怎样，下次见之前，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。我们很快、很快就会再聊。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的《艰难险阻》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方其实都不安全，但你正在与一个深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。
How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor Star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
多少男人穿着一身铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要去使用它，请在AHA电台应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，“单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranchini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
但这次怀孕似乎是个恶作剧。欧文斯女士，你对这个特定的测试造假了两次，对吗？我造假了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·兰奇尼。我的天哪，太震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿。
I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts,
在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇异现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和韧性的科学。经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。那是TWO%。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客上，
or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
或者在你获取播客的任何地方。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜们。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast, guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个IHeart播客，保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。